welcome to hannity again we begin
tonight with a fox news alert you the
american people you are now paying more
for a gallon of gasoline than ever
before in the history of this country
and it looks like it's only going to get
worse now joe biden's bold strategy to
let's see beg foreign dictators and
murderers and thugs to pump more oil
that's not working out particularly well
in fact according to an explosive report
in the wall street journal the leaders
of saudi arabia and the uae they won't
even take his phone calls
that doesn't get any more humiliating
than that now they are furious that joe
has become buddy buddy with the muellers
in iran once again they are the number
one state sponsor of terrorism in the
world why he's negotiating with freeing
up sanctioned money tens of billions of
dollars why he's talking about importing
oil from iran is beyond any
comprehension i have and according to
joe rising gas prices and well that's
not his problem there's nothing he can
really do about it take a look
can't do much right now
russia's responsible
it's all russia's fault except the
problem is something called the truth
now joe gas prices have been rising
since the day you were sworn in
and you canceled the keystone xl
pipeline you put a pause on new oil and
gas leases on all federal lands you
ended drilling an exploration in anwar
and alaska we have vast resources there
and rejoined the paris climate accords
you know the climate accords where we
pay all the money and china and india
are viewed as developing countries you
also enacted new regulations and
environmental restrictions on energy
production and yes under biden america
went from being a net exporter of energy
to a net importer of energy in less than
a year and joel lied about that earlier
today we are now producing less energy
than when donald trump left office and
that is just a fact and according to
biden his new domestic energy
restrictions has nothing to do with the
high cost of gasoline before
russia putin invaded ukraine we're
paying pretty close to a buck 50 more
gallon we were paying more to heat and
cool our homes and also paying more for
every item we buy in every store we go
to because of joe's economic and energy
policies but this is what he says
look let me be clear
about two other points first
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
second this crisis is a stark reminder
to protect our economy over the long
term we need to become energy
independent i've had numerous
conversations over the last three months
with our european friends of how they
have to wean themselves off of us
russian oil it's just not
it's just not tenable
it should motivate us to accelerate the
transition of clean energy
joe biden is simply lying if he wanted
to lift the restrictions that i just
laid out for you that would be
extraordinarily helpful to the energy
producing companies in this country but
he's not going to do it his press
secretary jenn saki has been lying
herself repeatedly suggesting oh the
free market's to blame that's another
lie according to her these greedy oil
companies are they're just sitting on 9
000 unused uh approved drilling permits
for no good reason at all that we need
to ask them why aren't they using those
those oil fields that we gave them well
jen we did as you asked and it turns out
you are deceptive and you're dishonest
let's look at what the american
petroleum institute says leases are
issued
prior to exploration
not every acreage of lease land has
resources to tap into that's why oil is
kind of a boom bust industry because
you're taking a bet that there might be
oil underground and sometimes it doesn't
work out that way now currently the
percentage of leases in production is
right now the highest in two decades in
other words with few exceptions the
leases that can be used they are being
used that's why joe needs to lift all
the restrictions that he put in place to
please the radical green new deal
socialist democrats jen do you got that
anyway now the oil industry is begging
for more access to drilling and
exploration and as the petroleum
institute put it quote it's time for the
administration to support domestic
production send a message that america
is open for energy investment why not
just be open and honest and say we made
a mistake we should never put these
restrictions on the energy sector that's
not within them i guess
jensac is more interested in auditioning
for a new job at fake news cnn or msdnc
than actually serve you the american
people that are paying the highest price
in history for a gallon of gasoline and
according to the climate alarmist cult
that is the new democratic party
america's biggest threat is not record
high gas prices or 40-year inflation
high no or war in europe or dependence
on foreign oil it's all about climate
change they want us to now transition
away from oil and gas as soon as
possible okay so if you're struggling to
fill up your tank if you're struggling
to heat your home if maybe you can't buy
the products that you really want to eat
in the store because it's too expensive
well the ever so uh let's see
experienced transportation secretary
mayor pete and vice president harris
they have a solution just go out and buy
yourself a brand new sixty thousand
dollar electric vehicle at your local
dealership
if they even have cars well
and while you're at it kamala harris
wants you to imagine a world imagine
close your eyeballs imagine for just a
second a world without the need for oil
and gas take a look
imagine all the heavy-duty vehicles that
keep our supply lines strong and allow
our economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it
that's why we're here today
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen
i feel like i'm back in first grade
whenever she gives a speech anyway if
she's ever president we are in deep
shift
anyway of course president trump was
right he warned us the gas prices they
would spike under biden and guess what
it's now happening take a look
we have so much oil we have more oil
than anybody okay and it's an incredible
thing that have it's over the last few
years a lot of great things and you're
paying what two dollars a gallon for
your gasoline that's okay
you know what that's like that's like a
tax cut
that's bigger than a tax cut
if biden got in you'd be paying seven
dollars eight dollars nine dollars
didn't they say get rid of your car
we're gonna build some more windmills
i'll put that in the column trump was
right again and that was not the only
thing president trump predicted
correctly in 2018 during his speech at
the u n he warned that europe's
dependence on russian oil and gas and
energy was a very dangerous game and
guess what they panned to the german
delegation when he was speaking about
them and they were laughing they thought
it was hysterical
i wonder if they're laughing today take
a look
reliance on a single foreign supplier
can leave a nation vulnerable
to extortion and intimidation
that is why we congratulate
european states such as poland
for leading the construction of a baltic
pipeline so that nations are not
dependent on russia
to meet their energy needs
germany will become totally dependent
on russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
here in the western hemisphere
we are committed
to maintaining our independence
from the encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers
i wonder if those guys are still
laughing today because germany is
essentially funding russia's deadly
invasion uh congratulations uh germany
for hurting europe once again back here
at home gas prices they're through the
roof everything you buy at every store
you go to as i said more expensive we
are now at a 40-year plus high with
inflation obviously the border is a
train wreck the economy is a train wreck
americans are still trapped in a
afghanistan that's an unforgivable train
wreck by the way if you're counting
today's day 206 since joe turned the
page and abandoned our fellow americans
behind enemy lines joe biden is in a
steep cognitive decline but
congratulations to the democrats that
means no more mean tweets
i hope it's worth it to you i hope that
we can survive three more years of what
has been the single worst administration
in modern american history and
especially the modern presidency now
maybe joe could learn a thing or two
about leadership and bravery from the
past maybe we can show him what courage
really looks like take a look
we shall fight in france
which will fight on the seas and oceans
we shall fight with growing confidence
and growing strength in the air
we shall defend our island whatever the
crowds may be
we shall fight on the beaches
we shall fight on the landing grounds
we shall fight in the fields
and in the streets which will fight in
the hills
we shall never surrender
we will not
give up
[Music]
in the forests in the fields
in the streets
blood toil tears and sweat i doubt it's
words that joe biden would even
recognize hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else